hello everybody my name is Marla thank
you nicely timed lightning bolt and
welcome back to spank you again you can
come now down further Thor anyway
welcome back to Spooky's House of
jump-scares
everyone wanted me to play this game
because I barely got through any of the
game in the first round so what about
news I'm gonna play back to where I was
before and then I'm gonna continue
deeper and deeper into Spooky's House of
jump because it actually does apparently
get really really really really creepy
down there so here we go
hope you like it wait does it remember
my game no it does not okay hello you
are stupid
yeah dinky dinky little skeleton brick
yeah mr. pumpkin are you going oh hey
what is this this is new why is it white
why is it pure white in here oh god this
is a puzzle isn't it oh I'm not gonna
find my way out of here
am i Oh ding okay left okay left left
okay left left now left left straight
damn it
aha I did it gay I solved a puzzle I
think I'm getting pretty close to where
it was before I should be able to pick
it up back now so welcome back everybody
to my playthrough we're gonna have so
much fun as we dive deeper into the
levels here and there's also gonna be
other puzzles that I'm gonna approach
and then I'm gonna fail at miserable I
haven't seen any of my previous notes so
that means either I'm getting somewhere
or someone is taking them not me never
do that I think this is my last note I'm
gonna die having never found my escape
but really that's not true this place
was like my escape my escape from
everything else in the end my death is
kind of romantic not really you're stuck
in a spooky house of jumpscares and you
drank some blood and then you went kind
of crazy from loneliness or whatever and
then you decided to fall over a 10-8
romantic at all but anyway I'm pretty
sure I only made it to like room 9 me
before there was that long hallway and
I'm not exactly sure how to beat about
that it involves not doing what I did
before I mean that could be said about a
lot of things but at least mr. inky man
isn't following me that makes me wonder
if the guy is that guy or if like
there's more monsters to this because
there was that whole file of various
monsters that were listed on the
computer that I found a while laya
a while ago I can't remember what room I
found it on but I think I got to the
point where I'm past where I was before
if I'm not mistaken I mean I keep
getting this long-ass room so I'm kind
of impeded on my progress here but
hopefully I'll be able to get through it
sooner or later damn it it's gone you
misled me with the chair I thought I was
gonna be somewhere before
know that you know grandpa crap Enki
guys back haha oh that's the guy oh no
way it's totally the guy he doesn't even
have a no left well he didn't make it
very far but I'm gonna make it farther
cuz I'm better than him her stuff they
no no no and also I didn't realize that
there was a safe I said I think I didn't
realize that there was a savegame
mechanic or else I would have been able
to pick it up before but I had to
redownload the game wasn't because I was
eating up the game grumps as hard drive
and I had to delete some of my older
stuff on here but either way I'm not
gonna worry about that
that's Resident Evil oh it is grimy in
here we're totally in a new territory
now so I'm Matt and we're gonna find it
new monster anytime soon did I mention
that I'm recording this after everyone's
gone out of the office again like for
the past few sessions I've had other
people here when I recorded this but not
today
[Music]
I'm kind of actually go alone now
windows bugging me again what the hell
is this a big giant pit of o's is that
booze it's gonna kill me they're gonna
be an whose monster that I need to worry
all this new what's going on
I know I know that on the surface this
game may seem cutesy and whatnot but
like it gets dark really quickly I
didn't even I didn't even dammit okay
right right
forward damn it right right forward nice
I got it yeah this game may seem cutesy
on the surface but there's a lot more
dammit God again punch Sassafrass
Bing bong ding dong ding dong I totally
guessed it ha ha guess good I'm kind of
sad now though because I'm not gonna be
able to get any more notes from my guy
cuz he's kind of really really really
dead whoa that's a thing I don't know if
I should stare at paintings I had bad
experiences with that in other horror
games also I don't know if any of the
cutesy people are gonna come pop it out
of me either I know that their kill
record is usually just no nevermind I'm
not going down long hallways where I see
a light at the end of it anymore that's
not my style bro whoa this is new
without this whoa okay maybe that's good
things are those eyes what the hell oh
my goodness
[Music]
okay I like this oh wow Oh what is this
what is that
well that's broken out that's a good
sign oh no oh no oh no
hello note subject five is growing more
and more restless I told spook we need
more funds for sedatives spook but she
just laughed and flew into the ceiling
without more chemicals to keep this
thing docile I'm not sure how much
longer we can keep them here safely
that's why I'm wondering if spook is
like some acronym for this like
organization that's growing all these
creatures and fats and we're unleashing
them in their own house what I gotta go
back bull honky ain't going back that
way so I got a key card this is the
first time where I it's not necessarily
randomized because this seems like it's
like I'm going back and forth between
the same place I believe subject 5 is
loose the glass around its container is
shattered and I can faintly hear
clicking coming from my wonder I wonder
if he really is loose his whole
enclosure has exploded from within I
don't know what will happen now if it is
out alive then this is probably my last
report the clicking is getting louder
clicking no thank you
no clicking no clicking for me why are
there holes in the ceiling no why are
there holes in the day like I'm the
ceiling wait they're tasty holes in the
ceiling I'm not gonna walk huh no screw
you
my list is coming back how many people
know but I actually had a speech
impediment for thanks for Santa winners
noise because I didn't go underneath the
pits of death that's an obvious Oh
goddammit guy you know like hate me no
man it's so weird because it's game the
woman yeah don't get me out of that pan
exhibit well it makes this game so
interesting is that it's it's so
contrarian like it's almost funny how
much like it's not what it seems to be I
guess it's it's the root of all comedy I
guess haha also you guys didn't know
this or you can't see this foot through
this window there's another room behind
it well that was all loud that was a
real noise damn it no no no no here in
real noises now that way beyond that
window there's an intermediate room but
beyond that there's another room with
another window and it's pitch black so
it's like just an ocean of pitch
blackness and I can see through to so
it's not good like if my god dammit this
place again so am I gonna hear clicking
noise I'm gonna hear clicking noise I
know I'm gonna hear clicky clicky clicky
clack he noise flicky cloggy
okay I'm fine okay I guess god dammit
I don't know what those things aren't
gonna get me oh how did they get me I
guess not not that bad anyway was that
whoa hello computer already been here
though
that's a cute face CAD Doss okay modify
house layout is this not it's not an
alien it's probably the same thing that
it was before what is specimen five ah
yeah okay
inside the Church of a small town ah yes
of course I am NOT weak-willed I'm a
strong will there's something I don't
know keep playing I'm almost at room 150
which I'm hoping there's gonna be
another save point when I get to that
place get in that door jump scares ain't
gonna be me I got it Bing bong Bing bong
give me another level baby give me
another monster baby give me something
okay there we go we're going down I
don't know what I'm gonna stop playing
but I'm gonna keep going for a long time
until my heart just explodes be good
it's gonna be good it's gonna be a good
game I really like it it's got so much
charm to it which is weird and to say to
describe a hoarding but it's nice to
have that because horror games often
take themselves very seriously and they
feel like they need to because horror is
often a very very serious subject damn
it horror is often a very serious
subject and he in a lot of ways it has
to be for the subject matter because
obviously if someone's laughing they
can't really be all that scared but I
don't know this one kind of splits the
line is it's it's cute and yet
terrifying I wouldn't say that is reach
terrifying it's not what I would call
horrifically terrible the worst scariest
game I've ever played in my life because
in a lot of ways it's got a really
creepy atmosphere and it's got jump
scares but I haven't reached the levels
that people are saying that it's like
the scariest game they've ever seen
their life oh it's like multiple Wow
although I would like to get like
someone to make an outside map to like
try to draw out way okay I don't think
those pits on the ceiling actually do
anything I think they're just a bunch of
book you would wave in Timmy Oh what is
this
okay the mood has shifted the mood has
stuff shifted when did I get into a
classroom with kids are why am i in a
Japanese classroom what's going on we
keep being taught down in the room and
level 165 this is a bunch of baloney I'm
gonna tolerate none of this Oh dad is
creepy I didn't even notice that at
first holy crap what the hell was that
happening in the other room and I just
didn't see it
[Music]
hi was that okay don't touch the shadow
people they're not good they're not good
for health
oh they're all looking at me huh spooky
want a piece of meat okay there was one
locked door in there I don't know if
there was like something fine could it
really be true
I thought the fairy tales about the
ghosts even children who sneak in after
class will just kill you three days to
bed but Matsui is still missing oh my
god is this is this a school from me Sal
is this where it got teleported to could
it be could it all be tied together
probably not but I bet there'll be a lot
of fan theories about that
[Music]
don't say to you yeah I've read not here
long night don't gonna deal with that
ball until that ball right saying about
how the mood wasn't shifting but as soon
as went into the classroom setting with
the old classic dark with a flashlight
click click just the old cuteness went
away really quickly it's amazing how
that happened so this game is like I
really really like this game I'm here to
see what else it has in store for me
because I often don't get surprised
anymore in the horror game
I guess maybe maybe that's why it's such
a cute to see atmosphere because it it
does benefit in the way that there is
more opportunity to be surprised as
opposed if it was serious 100% of the
time
because being serious 100% of the time
is good at all but it doesn't lead
itself to getting you like the essence
of John Scare and surprising me when you
least expected the essence of good scare
is just leaving you into a false sense
of security like where you think you're
going to die right after you feel like
you're safe and I think that actually
this game is doing that like it's really
doing it well like I'm very very pleased
to say that think I think that's gonna
be the dead end of it that way
I asked and of course I'm almost at room
200 I'll probably stop there and then
pick this up again later try to get
through another hundred floors or so I
don't know why we're going back to all
the light rooms I thought the with each
level I dropped down but I guess it
mixes and matches everything that it
could potentially do in the random level
generator
[Applause]
hey got a problem mate got a problem bub
huh
take it up with a chair that was a bad
joke that was a word I'm so sorry that
was the worst joke I've ever made in my
life I'm sorry I said that let's just
get to level 200 so I know okay I
thought it was gonna be the endless
looping okay I thought it was gonna be
the endless looping hallway that got me
killed last time I don't want to die
right before now okay so I saved the
game I'm still hanging in there little
ballsy this game is awesome if you
really want me to play more I will play
more even me why maybe staring at this
picture is just gonna eat my soul no
I'll risk it it's cute cat anyway so we
going even if you tell me you don't want
me to play it I'm probably gonna play it
but let me know stop it okay let me know
in the comments below what you figure
this and what lies in store for me down
the road thank you again everybody so
much for watching click the end to take
some more scary games I done watch the
first part if you haven't down in the
description below and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]